at what stage would labor have withdrawn
the whip from Michelle Moon well I mean
we wouldn't have made Michelle moan
appear in the first place there's a
there's a clear
um problem for the conservative party
here but it goes wider than just one
person there was a VIP express lane that
was set up for PPE and huge amounts of
money
um billions of pounds wasted because of
that and we yesterday set out that we
would ban those VIP express lanes going
forward Rishi note was the chancellor
who presided over all of this but the
more important problem for the country
is he's not promising to clean it up now
it's within his gift to do so and he
should make sure this never happens
again we needed PPE really quickly we
certainly did but one of the reasons
that we needed PPE really quickly is
because the government had a pandemic
plan that they didn't appear to know
about they hadn't done any of the drills
for several years the
um the equipment supplies that they were
meant to keep as part of that had been
severely deleted under the Cameron
government and when the pandemic hit
they were completely unprepared there
were other countries in the world who'd
borrowed our pandemic plan like so
Singapore who implemented it and did
significantly better than Britain and we
were left scrambling around with
emergency workers having to Source their
own because the government just wasn't
prepared so labor one of the first
things they would do even when they come
into power is to make sure that there's
a plan in place absolutely not just
having a plan in place because there was
a plan but that we were following that
plan and that we're ready for
emergencies in Wigan you know well okay
my own local Authority and public health
director were far better prepared than
their government and our Hospital trusts
managed to Source PPE far quicker than
the government and they did it in a
sensible way without wasting lots of
money they managed to get PPE that
actually worked rather than having this
bonfire of PPE afterwards and watching
not just PPE supplies that were faulty
go up in smoke but a lot of taxpayers
money at a time when we don't have a lot
of it talk about Wigan I mean would you
um would you be happy to have wind farms
onshore wind farms we absolutely would
and in fact I was in Lee just next door
um Last Friday Night with a public
meeting with people asking me why we
aren't able to build more onshore wind
farms people saying we want to set up
renewable Industries across the
Northwest we want to get cheaper access
to energy we want to create new jobs and
yet we've had an effective ban on them
for seven years the government is now
moving slightly under pressure from
their own back benches but the truth is
it's chaos they're being buffeted One
Way by about benches on house building
another way on onshore wind they don't
know what they're doing from one day to
the next to the consequence communities
can't plan either they do know that
there's a lot of challenges as far as
strikes are concerned I had Steve
Barclay sat there in the last hour and
he says his doors always open what more
can he do well the doors always open it
sounds like he's got no agency himself
if we were in government we'd be moving
Heaven and Earth to avoid these strikes
it's what the ambulance workers want
it's what the call handlers want they
don't want to be on strike they need him
to step up and do his job and get
involved in the negotiation so they can
go back to doing this well he should go
and talk to them I mean what you know
what does he think his actual job is he
hasn't spent a single second in
negotiations since this started and he's
got ambulance workers saying we don't
want to go on strike these strikes can
be avoided even now they can be avoided
if he actually did his job the problem
in this country isn't a militant
Workforce it's a militant government
um it's not just the ambulance drivers
of course I mean there are significant
numbers of unions that are planning to
go out on strike you recently said that
we we can't afford inflation busting pay
Rises no I said if they're unaffordable
it's because the government has crashed
the economy but the truth is that this
country does need a pay rise and the
government knows that privately they
completely accept it but inflation
busting no the inflation busting is is a
phrase that is used to try to disguise
the fact that there are a lot of people
now firefighters ambulance workers who
haven't had a proper pay increase for 12
years of Tory government and now are
being asked to go out and care for our
families when they can't afford to feed
their own it's unsustainable look the
point is this this is a really difficult
situation because for 12 years we've had
very little economic growth the Tories
have crashed the economy in the last few
months and left working people paying
the price but if you don't get money
back into people's pockets who care for
our families and run our public services
and work every single day to keep this
country going you can't rebuild local
economies you can't get economic growth
businesses can't Thrive and so the
government has got to sit down with the
Frontline Workforce that only two years
ago they were clapping for and calling
Heroes and try and work this out yeah I
don't know if you're much of a royalist
or not but how much sympathy have you
got for the king at the moment given
what's happening the other side of the
pond I've got a lot of sympathy actually
for the whole royal family you know
families are complicated they're
difficult I know that myself and it's
not easy when you're going through what
this family is going through actually my
heart goes out to all of them I think
watching all of that playing out through
the national newspapers must be pretty
desperate for everybody involved yeah
but it should you really be doing
Netflix documentaries about I mean you
wouldn't do a Netflix documentary about
your family I'm sure it would be a good
watch
they won't either
nobody ever knows what really goes on in
families if you're not part of it and
there's always about 20 different
versions as I know myself the you know
the the you've got Harry and Megan
saying that there there's briefing and
there's leaking going on which must be
pretty brutal if it's true you've got
you know the other side of the family
saying well it's it's not right to do
Netflix documentaries which you know
pretty brutal if it's true I'm not in a
position to comment I don't think
anybody really in this country is yeah
the nandi's a blockbuster series coming
to a screen
it's good to see you as always thanks
very much thank you